everyone Jack Whitehall is on tour yes
he is around
Jack Whitehall gets around then you
start on the 5th of March and next year
and then you go all around the country
when you finish on the 16th of March
around a lot it's very compact to Brian
I'm aging lots of places it is my
biggest joy I've ever done I'm doing it
I'm doing in the round which is new also
feeling warm updates before I start in
Aberdeen and then I end in Wembley and
it's so quite well in some places not in
Aberdeen so that's the kind of you know
the main thrust is if anyone is watching
from Aberdeen I just need to sell one
more ticket and there will be more
people in the audience than there are on
stage and that's what we need please I
love Aberdeen as well can I just take
this opportunity I'm a big fan yes you
see I love it a fish trawler port which
is the biggest in Europe oh you're good
yeah um is that so it's that sort of
local stuff love the fact that in
Aberdeen more medieval coin holidays
have been found than anywhere else in
the UK right this is approximately 4,000
feet in elevation the river D rises at
approximately
what else is great about Aberdeen and
why I'm really looking forward to gain
there it's where else when you find a
city where Robert Henderson Robert
Henderson designed the first iron lung
in Aberdeen in 1933
we love you Avenue so what what a
perfect place to start my trip and
whiter
you look scary like a woman I had a
one-night stand with him Wiggin
was me the other do you all do all one
and then go back to the other one when I
do a table read yeah I have to jump back
and forth right okay how much going on
hello sad man arse doing away it's good
right that is good